luxembourg is a tiny country measuring
just 82 kilometers from north to south
and 52 kilometers from west to east and
its resident population is only around
643 000. for a country this small one
official language is probably enough
right well luxembourg actually has three
official languages german french and
luxembourgish the national language
which has historically been spoken here
53 percent of residents regularly speak
luxembourgish at home 32 percent speak
french around 11 percent speak german
and 19 speak portuguese a language
spoken by many immigrants about 7.6
percent speak english at home hold on a
minute those numbers don't add up to 100
percent that's right because lots of
people speak more than one language at
home are you starting to get a picture
of the rich linguistic situation in
luxembourg
47 of the population of luxembourg are
foreign residents and if we include
people who don't live in luxembourg but
commute there for work from the
surrounding countries over 70 percent of
the people in luxembourg on a daily
basis are foreigners
many people are bilingual and code
switch between various languages
throughout the day which language they
use depends on the individual and who
they're talking to but also depends on
the context seventy-four percent of
people work in a multilingual workplace
with french being the most widely used
followed by english luxembourgish german
and portuguese
why does luxembourg have three official
languages well there are geographic and
historical reasons for this luxembourg
is situated at the point where germany
france and the french-speaking part of
belgium intersect west central german
dialects have historically been spoken
in the neighboring regions of germany
and walloon one of the longdoi closely
related to french has historically been
spoken in the neighboring regions of
france and belgium the luxembourg
dynasty of the 14th and 15th centuries
was larger than luxembourg's current
size and included some of these
neighboring regions
the written and administrative language
in walloon-speaking areas was french
even though french was different from
walloon it was closely related and was
commonly written the written and
administrative language in west central
german-speaking areas was german which
again was not the same as the local
vernacular speech but german was used as
the written language alongside varying
spoken dialects as it developed and
became more standardized but in
luxembourg city itself the
administrative language was french even
though the native language of the people
was a west central german dialect a
moselle franconian dialect
after the french occupied luxembourg in
1795 strong priority was given to french
even in the german-speaking zones
after luxembourg's independence from the
french its land was reduced to its
current small size located entirely in a
german-speaking area and when i say
german i mean the moselle franconian
dialect that came to be known as
luxembourgish one might expect that
german would have been made the
administrative language because of its
similarity to the local's native dialect
but french continued to fulfill that
role and became a required subject in
schools in addition to german this was
partly to keep luxembourg distinct from
other german-speaking countries and
avoid being swallowed up by them they
also began to emphasize that their
moselle franconian dialect was their
national language and distinct from
german and people began trying to
standardize its written form a process
which continued for much of the 20th
century in 1984 luxembourgish finally
became an official language alongside
german and french as well as the
national language as i mentioned before
luxembourgish is a west central german
dialect specifically a moselle
franconian dialect that's been
standardized just across the border in
germany moselle franconian dialects may
be considered part of the german
language because they use it in tandem
with standard german which functions as
the formal and written language but
because the dialect spoken in luxembourg
has been standardized and formalized
with a written form and is not only used
for casual conversation it's considered
its own language but it has also
developed in its own direction based on
the linguistic realities of life in
luxembourg adopting loanwords from
french and english as well as standard
german for instance there are also local
dialects within luxembourg that have
gradually converged towards a more
unified standard variety that's unique
to luxembourg
since it developed from a central german
dialect that's also spoken in germany is
luxembourgish very similar to standard
german let's find out but first a
message from our sponsor me did you know
that i have a second channel on the
geofocus channel which i recently
rebooted after a five-year hiatus i talk
about various countries of the world
global issues and so on if you like
educational videos like this one then
check out the geofocus channel the link
is in the description and pinned comment
of this video
now back to luxembourgish
here are a handful of basic words and
phrases in luxembourgish alongside
standard german equivalents hello in
luxembourgish you could say it any of
these ways hello
this is the word for morning and in
german hello
goodbye in luxembourgish adi and in
german
note that the luxembourgish word comes
from the french word adi
yes no
in luxembourgish
and in german
thank you merci danke
you probably noticed that this is
another loan word from french
excuse me to get someone's attention and
cherished
luxembourgish also has the word pardon
from french which is used like excuse me
but more in the sense of saying sorry
the word and
can also be used for apologies sorry i'm
late and cherished for spedung or using
the french word [ __ ] and chilish
and in german and truly
but in luxembourgish both of these ways
of saying it would be quite formal a
more casual way of saying it would be to
use the english word sorry sorry
where's the train station in
luxembourgish
and in germany
again the word gar in the luxembourgish
sentence comes from the french word for
train station so after just a few basic
examples you can see that french has had
a significant influence on luxembourgish
vocabulary also notice that cognate
verbs have slightly different forms in
either language
pronunciation and orthography
luxembourgish has some features of
phonology that differ from those of
standard german and some of the
differences are reflected in
luxembourgish orthography one important
feature is the eiffel rule words that
end in n normally drop the n if the next
word begins with a consonant other than
n d t z or h we saw this before in the
word mei in the sentence and chilish mei
[ __ ] this is a feature of the spoken
language that arose naturally not only
in moselle franconian dialects but to
varying degrees in all of the western
group of high german dialects including
west central german high franconian and
alamanic dialects in luxembourgish the
eiffel rule also affects the written
language because the spelling reflects
pronunciation but it doesn't affect all
words in fact it doesn't affect most
nouns and adjectives
luxembourgish has both stressed personal
pronouns and unstressed personal
pronouns in which some sounds are
dropped or reduced in lots of languages
unstressed vowels are reduced but in
luxembourgish the reduced pronunciation
is reflected in the standard spelling
for example the first singular dative
pronoun meaning to me
and the third person singular masculine
nominative accusative pronoun meaning he
he
grammar while standard german has four
noun cases luxembourgish has just two
well you could say that there are three
nominative accusative and dative but the
nominative and accusative have the same
form aside from different singular and
plural forms the nouns themselves don't
change depending on case only
determiners such as these definite
articles and adjectives this is the same
as in standard german
the mom the mom
note that the masculine nominative
accusative form and the plural dative
form can either end in n or not end in n
in accordance with the ifla rule that we
heard about before
for the masculine nominative and
accusative compare the mum with the hunt
meaning the dog and for the plural
dative compare the manner with
meaning to the dogs the luxembourgish
genitive is normally expressed with the
dative case plus a possessive adjective
there normally isn't a separate genitive
form for example the manzaine hunt
meaning the man's dog word for word it's
to the man his dog this isn't limited to
luxembourgish and occurs in various
dialects throughout the german-speaking
regions but not in standard german
in standard german there's a separate
genitive case
there's a difference in comparative
forms between luxembourgish and standard
german in luxembourgish the comparative
form usually uses me meaning more rather
than an er form let's take for example
this sentence meaning she's taller than
you see us make rose face too word for
word she is more tall as you and it's
standard german she is too literally she
is taller as you note that while german
has a cognate of they which is v instead
of german it wouldn't be used in a
comparison sentence like this it's used
in an equal comparative like as tall as
in some german dialects though v or its
dialectal equivalent might be used just
like in luxembourgish also note that the
personal pronouns in either language are
similar if we look at all the personal
pronouns of both languages we can see
that they're mostly similar with some
differences in form the third person
masculine and neuter forms the first
person plural and the second person
plural are different though the first
person plural pronoun mia or similar can
be found in other german languages like
in dialects of spoken swiss german and
bavarian in which it's mia
but this luxembourgish sentence is
polite and formal in a casual familiar
context it would be how does megro's
face do note the different personal
pronoun hot actually functions as a
third person singular neuter pronoun
even though it's only used to refer to
females
there are some slight differences in
verb tenses and verb conjugations
between luxembourgish and german the
past tense is expressed using a compound
tense in luxembourgish except for a
small number of special common verbs the
compound past uses the present perfect
form but with past meaning it consists
of the auxiliary verb
meaning to have or
meaning to be plus the participle of the
main verb for example in luxembourgish
this means i slept literally i have
slept
hoon is the first person singular
present form of hun the first person
singular present form is the same as the
infinitive for most verbs so why is it
missing the nn at the end of the
infinitive well that's the ifla rule
again
geschloef is the participle form of
schlofen and the standard german
sentence
meaning i slept schlieff is the first
person singular preterite form of
schlafen but in standard german as well
this is more of a formal or written form
in colloquial speech the present perfect
is used like in luxembourgish
literally i have slept
the conditional some luxembourgish verbs
have a simple conditional conjugation
but they have mostly disappeared from
the language and the conditional is
normally expressed using a compound form
it uses the conditional form of the
auxiliary verb
which by itself means give or become
plus the infinitive of the main verb for
example
meaning i would sleep in german the
conditional is formed using the
subjunctive ii form
but this is very formal much more
commonly the compound form is used
with the auxiliary verb verden in its
subjunctive two form plus the infinitive
of the main verb so it's similar to the
compound conditional in luxembourgish
but the auxiliary verb is different note
that the auxiliary verb meaning to have
and the verb meaning to sleep have
different forms and their conjugations
are different even though they're
cognates and developed from the same
root they're actually both irregular
verbs in both languages so let's compare
the conjugations of regular verbs you
can see that the verb endings added to
the verb base are largely the same in
luxembourgish and in standard german but
the first person singular and second
person singular are slightly different
notice again that in luxembourgish the
first person singular resembles the
infinitive because of its ending here's
a sentence meaning you don't drink beer
do you in luxembourgish you drink beer
order word for word it's you drink not
beer right and in standard german
word for word it corresponds exactly
with the luxembourgish sentence now this
is just the present tense but of course
such differences in conjugated forms
occur in all tenses and verb
constructions while we're looking at
these sentences notice the luxembourgish
negation word
which again loses its final n in the
sentence because of the eiffel rule it's
a cognate of the german word
in both languages this word negates
nouns the luxembourgish word that
negates verbs and adjectives is
a cognate of german
here's a sentence meaning i'm not
interested in luxembourgish
and in german
also notice the different first-person
singular verb forms in luxembourgish
zinn and in standard german
the first person singular of zen
let's look at a final sentence and break
it down if i were you i'd look for a new
job first in luxembourgish
if i you were would i for myself uh new
job seek and in standard german
where for word it's in your place would
i for myself a new job seek
notice that the sentences are worded
differently at the beginning with the
luxembourgish clause meaning if i were
you and the german clause meaning in
your place
but in german it could also be
which corresponds exactly to the
luxembourgish clause
in luxembourgish as well you could use a
phrase corresponding with the german
phrase andinga platz meaning in your
place
notice the conditional verb in the
second clause again it's the compound
conditional but again notice the
different auxiliary verbs notice again
that most of the luxembourgish and
german words are cognates with slightly
different forms and pronunciation this
indefinite article and this adjective
are in the feminine singular accusative
form just like the german equivalent
this word abused is clearly a cognate of
the german word
and both are feminine
all in all the luxembourgish and
standard german sentences are very
similar but with lots of little
differences
as you can see luxembourgish is closely
related to standard german which makes
sense since it's based on a dialect
that's part of the high german dialect
continuum from which standard german
arose speakers of very similar moselle
franconian dialects across the border in
germany can easily understand
luxembourgish and feel like they're
speaking the same language though they
may be momentarily thrown off by some of
the french loanwords but luxembourgish
has considered its own language because
it has its own standardized form and is
used in formal situations and in writing
unlike related dialects in germany and
unlike in germany where regional
languages and their dialects are
gradually fading away in favor of
standard german luxembourgish is
becoming more established as the
national language of luxembourg the
question of the day to citizens and
residents of luxembourg
how much do you use luxembourgish and
what other languages do you use
regularly and to speakers of standard
german and other germanic languages how
well do you understand luxembourgish
does it feel very similar to your own
language and once again it's time to say
thanks to the langfocus patreon
supporters especially the ones whose
names appear on the screen they are the
top tier patreon supporters so many
extra special thanks to them visit
patreon.com langfocus to find out how
you can become a patron too and to
everyone thank you for watching and have
a nice day
[Music]
you